any move we make um
you know we try to think about the long
term
uh now you know you could probably pick
and choose some moves where maybe
contractually it doesn't seem like it's
long term but you know within the within
the building and within the meeting
rooms we think about it more for
long-term purposes as we move forward
here but uh yeah i think all those guys
came in and contributed
bill o'brien coach of the texans his end
of season press conference peter and
look they made a lot of moves right at
the end of the pre-season labor day
weekend some surprising moves they paid
a big chunk of jaedaveon clowney's
salary to get him off the books to get a
third round pick for him kind of a
strange move there they gave up a ton
for laramie tunsil at left tackle and
kenny stills the receiver from miami
they didn't get tunsle signed to a
long-term contract two first-round picks
go out the door as part of that deal and
they're not going to hire a gm bill
o'brien acknowledged that yesterday i i
really have a concern about that because
i think there's always needs to be
a voice in the organization that can
push back against the things that the
head coach would like to do and that
maybe bill o'brien has been able to do
unfettered without a gm there
mike what would you do what would you
say if i told you that houston which has
so many needs
uh in this draft in this offseason
coming up specifically they desperately
need a corner they desperately need to
replace the pass rusher they lost in
jadavian county they need help on the
offensive line
you wonder about the long term future
of so many things on their team
the houston texans are going to have one
draft choice in the top 120 picks
in this draft
one draft choice out of the top 120.
let's let's track it they lose the one
for laramie tunzel
they use their two
threes in this draft including the one
they got
for um
for clowney
for gary and conley
and duke johnson
so now all they have left is i think
it's the 57th pick
in the fir in the in the in the draft
which is their second round pick
so
i think they're going to have huge
buyers remorse
as they look at the composition of what
they have available to do
this winter and spring
to supplement a team that needs a lot of
supplements
and they're going to have to pay some of
the guys they already have tunsil is in
the final year of his rookie contract
that fifth year option
and he'll head toward free agency the
franchise tag after the 2020 season
deshawn watson the window is open on a
second contract for him and they gave jj
watt his second contract after three
seasons they made jadavian clowney play
out his entire five-year rookie deal and
then traded him from under the franchise
tag i think it's only fair to give
deshaun watson his contract in this
off-season now will they want to pay him
what watson wants where does the market
go if i'm watson i wait to see what
patrick mahomes gets and i try to come
in under that and if patrick mahomes
gets 40 million a year do you put desean
watson between 35 and 40 million it's
going to be a challenge and the texans
could just decide to squat on desean
watson knowing that he's not going to
make a big deal about it and take
advantage of his good nature some big
decisions to make though a tough
negotiation with tunsil tough
negotiation with watson holes to fill no
draft picks to fill them which means
fewer options to get young cheap talent
this is not going to be an easy off
season or two for the texans peter all
the more reason to have a gm
if i were bill o'brien
i would try to sign desean watson as
soon as possible you know why
all you do by waiting all you do it's
gonna cost you three or four million a
year on the cap
don't wait
pay too much now because too much now is
going to be a lot less than you'd have
to pay later
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports